I'm joined today by Dan Buettner who is
an internationally recognized National
Geographic Explorer who's worked in five
places in the world that He has called
Blue Zones where humans lived the
longest and are the healthiest we've
talked about some of these areas
individually before dan how did you
first get into this area of research I
had been an explorer for National
Geographic and others for about 12 years
and I've specialized really in
harnessing an online audience to help
solve mysteries like why the Maya
civilization collapsed did Marco Polo go
to China and I sort of stumbled upon an
interesting mystery in Okinawa in the
year 2000 the World Health Organization
found that they had the longest
disability free life expectancy in the
world in other words people live a long
time without getting disease and I go
aha now there's a good mystery and I
hastily organized an expedition about
eight of us to explore that mystery and
realize that the vein was much richer
than I thought it was going to be indeed
there was it wasn't a genetic mystery it
was a lifestyle environment mystery and
I could already start to see the things
that were contributing to Okinawa
incidentally has about 30 times more
female centenarians for people over 50
than we do in America it's it's just
often off the charts and then reason
there must be other pockets around the
world where people live a long time and
proposed research grant to the National
Institutes on aging and got a big
assignment from National Geographic to
to approach this correctly and and we're
off and running that was 12 years ago
and in addition to Okinawa which we've
heard about quite a bit on the program
tell us about what other areas you
identified as these blue zones so the
highlands of Sardinia specifically the
Nauru and Olli Oscar provinces longest
of males in the world are there in
Koya Peninsula of Costa Rica just south
of Nicaragua Louis disability free
highest disability free life expect a
life expectancy among people are 50 and
then it Korea Greece an island off of
Turkey about not about 10,000 people
interesting they're not only live about
seven years longer than Americans but
almost completely dementia free an team
with the University of Athens found
almost everybody over the age of 60 on
the entire island and gave them the same
cognitive tests that the National
Institute on Aging uses and found almost
no dementia in America here if you had a
t5 there's about a 50% chance you're
suffering from dementia and then in the
United States we've found the most
extraordinary population among
seventh-day adventists
in and around Loma Linda California a
population that lives about 10 years
longer than their Californian
counterparts so we also profiled them in
some detail as well so talk to us about
what were the commonalities between
these different populations that you
found so this last book the blue zone
solution I took a dietary approach it's
not all diet but I'm gonna start with
diet because I think died is the runway
for getting people interested in
healthier lifestyle so we did have
meta-analysis of 155 dietary studies
done over the past hundred years in all
five blue zones and we found that
between 90 and a hundred percent of
their dietary intake came from plants
they did eat meat but only on average
about five times a month surprisingly
little fish you know we tend to think
that omega-3 and fish but not in Blue
Zones very high carb diet flies right in
the face of these high protein
suggestions we hear from you know paleo
people and so forth but but about 70% of
their calories came from carbohydrates
and that was mostly Whole Grains things
like rice sourdough bread was a big
contribute
beans about a cup of beans a day and all
these booze owns that alone probably
adds three to four years of life
expectancy and greens so that trifecta
beans greens and grains is is basically
what people eat these blue zones and I
think accounts for for most their
dietary longevity but also they have
vocabulary for purpose they have a
reason to get up in the morning and and
keep their mind sharp and their bodies
agile and stay engaged they tend to
belong to a faith of the 255
centenarians I interviewed I've found
only a handful that did not have a faith
so that seems to contribute 4 to 14
extra years of life expectancy depending
on who you are
they they have daily rituals to reverse
the worry and the hurry of everyday life
through prayer meditation happy hour
even now is a very effective way of
lowering cortisol levels and lowering
your chance of heart disease by about
30% they don't exercise hard which is
interesting I was just reading the New
York Times this story finding that
people who exercise hard
stress strenuously actually I have a
higher chance of getting colds in the
winter season here and people who just
have regular low intensity physical
exercise actually have a stronger immune
system and what are you talking about
when you say lower intensity I mean
certainly it sounds like walking I know
in Okinawa gardening is a very very
common activity exactly gardening
walking you know their houses are set up
where we they have an engineered out the
physical activity like there isn't a
button to push for yard work and another
button to push for God for house work
and another button to push for kitchen
work there they're you know grinding
corn by hand or kneading bread dough and
and their life is just laced with
regular low intensity physical activity
that's
stressing their body like strenuous
exercise does but keeping it moving and
keeping apparently the immune system
stronger yeah and none of these blue
zones are people pumping iron or running
triathlons or doing extreme sports of
any kind so Dan you've said in your TED
talk that this is about 10% genetics and
90% lifestyle of the 90% lifestyle can
you break it down any further in terms
of how much is diet and how much is
activity and whatever other components
there are there how much more can we
fine-tune that 90% well regular physical
activity and eat a plant-based diet will
get you most of those extra years but I
will tell you so that so you know you
can tell people all day long David and
I'm sure on your show you've heard other
people say yeah get exercise and and you
know eat your veggies and so forth in
people's eyes glaze over but the the the
big aha moment that the big epiphany
after about six years of research was
the insight about how you actually get
people to do the right thing for long
enough and in Blue Zones and none of
these places do you see did you see
these spry centenarians who said when
they were 50 well god I'm gonna get on
that longevity diet or they didn't buy a
treadmill or you know start taking
supplements in all blue zones what
longevity happens to these people it in
America we tend to go after health is
something we're gonna proactively go
after we're gonna buck up get discipline
change the way we live and and try to
eat right that never works what does
work is shaping your environment so that
the healthy choice is not only the easy
choice but also the unavoidable choice
and you see this in these blue zones
it's their fruits and vegetables and
beans and grains they're the most
they're the cheapest foods around and
they're easy to get there
not tempted by burgers and pizzas and
fries and sodas and candy bars they have
time-honored recipes to make those foods
taste good I could tell you broccoli and
and Goa bitter melon are the healthiest
longest the healthiest foods on earth
best longevity foods on earth but if you
don't like broccoli and Goya you you
might eat them for a few weeks or a few
months but you're not going to eat a mug
enough to get the extra year so it's
making the right foods taste good they
have their kitchen setup so they're easy
to make and probably most importantly
there's social networks or says the
people they hang out without eating
these foods too so they're not making
this wonderful it Korean stool out of
black-eyed peas and fennel and then go
into their friends house or eat you know
grilling burgers or baby back ribs and
they all eat these foods so you know the
key to longevity really is knowing the
right foods to eat but then setting up
your social network making sure you have
friends you want to eat with come to
visit you to whom you visit that are
eating this way and living this way and
that way it'll stick so really you could
give Americans for example the list as
we're sort of describing it here but if
the list is just something that
Americans have to remember to check off
so to speak versus it coming naturally
from changes to culture it sounds like
it's going to be pretty difficult to
actually make a long-term change isn't
it that's right no diet in the history
of the world and I've done the research
on this last for more than about four
four ninety six ninety seven percent of
people last for more than two years when
it comes to longevity there's no
short-term fix David you can't run out
there's no pill right now there's no
hormone there's no genetic intervention
none of that stuff that we spend sixty
billion dollars a year on works at
longevity the only thing that works that
we know of our long-term intervention
things you're gonna do for four decades
so you start asking yourself how do you
set up your life so the right thing
so I'll be doing the right things in the
year you know 2026 and the types of
things that work are moving to the right
place you move to a place that have
healthy defaults setting up making new
friends who are you're likely going to
be hanging out with in a decade who are
a and there's friends have a measurable
impact on what you eat it is of course
important to know the right foods to eat
you know I like to think we did a good
job at that Blue Zones but also set it
up your attention so it's easy to make
those foods and you know and then
knowing your sense of purpose because
you need you need propulsion you need
that will to go after these things and
if you're waking up aimlessly in the
morning it's it's it's it's hard to
McKee up firt well it's absolutely
fascinating we've been speaking with Dan
Buettner about his Blue Zones work check
out there's so much about this on his
website you can google Dan Buettner Blue
Zones and there will be reading for a
while Dan thanks so much for talking to
us about this I enjoyed it David thanks
for calling